i
took my music off of uh streaming
platforms right now you know i'm saying
why is it so
because um i was not
getting the return on my investment
on the music from the streams i just
wasn't getting enough streams yeah for
people who don't know like a million
streams is like thirty eight hundred
dollars on something you know what i'm
saying and i would spend
thirty eight hundred dollars it's just
you know what i mean it's just to make
the song like you know what i'm saying
by the beach through the videos
so if i'm in a red and i'm not and i'm
not streaming a million
you know what i'm saying i'm not so i'm
not getting my bread so
it's just basically throwing my bread
you know what i mean and i'm not getting
it back and i'm thinking about other
ways to make money so it's kind of just
chasing a dream
that's like you know so i did that [ __ ]
for so long i'm just like
hold on bro you know what i'm saying
hold on
um um i was thinking about quitting like
you know what [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah i mean
and uh and my bro shooter shooting 93
shout out to shooter
he he gets on my live and he's like yo
bro you know just
just just just i had already took my
music down cause i'm like oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] man i'm done with this [ __ ] [ __ ] it
i'm saying so shooter was like yo just
sell your music directly to your people
you fool me
and then and then get your bread and
then after once you get your bread
then you can do what you want you know
i'm saying the money is the issue right
so like
as long as you're getting the bread
right then you can once you have
once you amassed enough money then you
can do whatever you want you could play
however you want to play you know i'm
saying so i was like
so he was like yo you you did a good job
in cultivating
a fire base yeah right so now and you
got super like
i got following that you know what i'm
saying they must have been heartbroken
you took the music down right
i was still on itunes though no no i
mean some maybe like six songs
that's it right damn
mostly my collabs you know what i'm
saying mostly on youtube
i took all that [ __ ] down wow um i took
all of it down
would you consider putting it back up
because if you got some hardcore fans
they got to be like
man bro right i mean i mean
i mean i might put it back up but right
now
um i'm selling it you know what i'm
saying so if if you're not hardcore
if you're if you're if you're a
supporter then you won't buy it and
that's been working out
and it's been working out i made more
money in [ __ ] five days
than i made in the whole three years and
on music we know who's done a good job
of that
is uh rock rock marcy right shout out to
rock monsieur my bro shooter he does
that
tyler quality was doing that for a while
where you had to like go to his website
to get his music
so at the end of the day i feel like you
know as an artist we gonna have to just
you know everybo everything ain't for
everybody you know what i'm saying like
i have to understand
my market is different than say you know
dude if you got a thousand people
that'll just
pay for what you do it's gonna be good
i'm good
you know what i'm saying so get your
merch popping right hey look
we got you you could drop an album once
a month and hit a check right
and that's what i've been cultivating
you feel me just taking advantage of the
the base that i want to see so for so
long i'm
worrying about chasing people versus
really
cultivating the people that already are
there you [ __ ] with me you feel me so
now
now i've just been focused on that and
then once i get my
my situation right then if i want to put
streams then at least i have to brag to
go crazy because right now
us as independent artists you feel me
unless we
especially if we do genres that's
different than you know what's what's
trending right now
you feel me so like you know we have to
you know
if we kind of in a race like we kind of
in a rat race
we got to come up with you know we have
to pay for the stew like the artist is
the last person to get paid
always you feel me like we got to pay
the the the producer gets paid director
gets paid the engineer gets paid
graphics guys the graphics guy
everybody gets paid then then after you
make the video man you make all that
then you got to pay the [ __ ]
spotify playlist you gotta pay these
people
that people blogs and all this [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying oh you wanna do a
reaction video or y'all pay that pay
this pay that pay that
it's a whole you were you kind of in
that in that um
that that because you know like you said
you got
to get to get some of these youtubers to
do a reaction video you got to cut a
check you got like a lot of this [ __ ]
it's like everything is
everyone's getting a bag right now
exactly except
except the artist except unless you're
on tour
or you're [ __ ] like shout out to
griselda because griselda anybody on
their label like
conway benny gunn will drop a sweater
and make 250 grand off of it you know
what i mean like
but like in general what they did was
they just focused
on who they who [ __ ] with them already
and then and then they grew it from
there you feel me
and they still make the same like i hate
when the [ __ ] they didn't change
well i i'm like and they've they've
obviously out elevated in some of the
sounds that they but they're still them